all the best memories of hers
Ryan's Blade Runner 2049 co-star
Harrison Ford is also opening up about
his marriage in this new Esquire cover
story
the 80 year old reveals kalista
Flockhart is not a fan of his habit of
cursing through interviews while also
dropping a new expletive quote my wife
is still giving me bleeps Harrison is
also opening up about how he landed one
of his big Series where Taylor shared
and whined and dine you into joining
1923. that's pretty much true I should
mention it was a really good wine f
William Hurt in 2024's Captain America
New World Order we fight what is it that
attracts you about being in the Marvel
Universe yeah it just seems like
everybody's having a lot of fun a bunch
of good actors having a lot of fun but
one film that wasn't so much fun to
shoot New York's finest
his 1997 drama with Brad Pitt the
devil's own quote Brad developed the
script I admire Brad I think he's a
wonderful actor but then all of a sudden
we're shooting and we didn't have a
script that Brad and I agreed on it was
complicated
foreign